leave me alone
how will you say that this is a scam PhD
v11 with your hands oh is this is a this
is number 11 okay what's up guys
mkbhd here welcome to ask mkbhd version
11 there are plenty of questions of
course I asked you guys on Twitter what
you guys wanted to know there's been
plenty of uploads in the past month
planning to talk about plenty of tech
releases just let's just go grab the
surface studio or wait for refresh with
better specs
okay so I've seen the surface studio
people are asking why I didn't cover it
I was on a plane during that on the way
to the Apple event so I was watching it
on this crappy Wi-Fi but I'm aware of it
should you get one now obviously it
looks really cool
you can always be waiting for better
specs I don't think you need to wait
it's a brand new product you can feel
free to be safe and get it now but yeah
I think this is a product that's going
to be continued by Microsoft it's kind
of ridiculously good-looking and I hope
there's many more guilty pleasures of
this year's tech of this year's um I
don't I don't think I really have any
fur this year what I will say though I
haven't really told many people this the
Moto 360 like the original with the the
circle but the flat tire on the bottom
that's one of my favourite SmartWatch
designs ever like since the beginning
there's been like years of smartwatches
since then and everyone's like oh I want
the full circle I don't care if I need a
bigger bezel that flat tire design is
ugly I kind of really liked it do you
love the pixel as much as you thought
you would and has become your daily
driver yes it is my daily driver it's
the phone I'm testing right now my main
sin is in it and this is actually one of
those phones that I like more than I
thought I would we all you know or
smartphone enthusiasts we look at the
specs when we see it announced we're
maybe not the most impressed with the
pixel it's not water resistant you know
it doesn't have expandable storage it's
not the prettiest design when you see it
on paper or in an ad when you condense a
phone down to just the experience of
using it just the software experience of
what makes these phones
what made previous Nexus is so good it
reminds you a lot of what makes a phone
good this phone is a lot better in
person than any video or tutorial or
review can really show you that being
said I am definitely reviewing it when
will we see the studio tour soon I
actually shot it already and I shot it
in 360 so if you saw the snapchat
teasers or the two
or teasers if he following you've
already noticed this but I've shot the
studio tour it's you know sent evolving
space there's going to be more stuff
coming in and out of here all the time
but for those of you who are curious and
kind of want to know the general layout
of what it looks like that's going to be
a video that's upcoming very soon so
thumbs up if you're excited to see that
hopefully it drops on your sub box
shortly if you were Tim Cook for a brief
period of time I guess if I was a CEO of
Apple for a second or two what tasks
would you have deployed to the Apple
engineers that's easy uh new Mac Pro
please in matte black with the new chips
do it now do it what is your go-to tech
gift for this holiday season for those
all these price range ideas so for
twenty to fifty bucks that's kind of in
your like non-functional accessory
market like if I'm talking about
smartphones
that's your screen protectors your skins
your cases stuff like that or 50 to 100
bucks that's getting into more of like
your functional accessories so things
actually do stuff so like a battery case
to have extra battery life or maybe like
one of those cradles or extra lenses on
the back of the smartphone shoot better
video 100 to 250 bucks is sort of an
awkward range for a smartphone related
gift but if you're into stuff like mid
to high end headphones that can be an
idea and then from 250 to 500 bucks you
can get a smartphone for this price you
can get a great smartphone for this
price I've recommended a couple already
I've shown some this year the oneplus 3
comes to mind coz that's automatically
at the top of my list for under 500
bucks but there's plenty of others from
moto and Xiaomi and others so why are
you still using an aged Mac Pro instead
of maybe a faster and updated Windows
setup okay so yeah I've talked a little
bit about this on Twitter but I'm still
using you can't really see it but way
back there the Mac Pro the trashcan
which came out in 2013 when I mentioned
I was actually considering getting a
fully top-spec maxed out MacBook Pro to
replace that on my desktop ton of
questions came to mind number one is why
don't you switch to like a Windows
bilges build a Windows PC and learn
premiere or Vegas or something like that
I've actually been using Adobe Premiere
for nearly a decade believe it or not
like seven years of using Adobe Premiere
so it's not like I need to learn
something new
I switched in the last year to Final Cut
Pro for a reason and as performance and
I'm not really switching that Macintosh
doesn't really work for me I mean maybe
as a recreational project it's fun but
the reliability isn't there for a full
time machine to edit videos every day
so yeah that's kind
where I'm at is like I I want a new Mac
Pro obviously like I've said but there's
not a whole lot of options for a
high-end machine that I can do do them
on it maybe an iMac maybe like a matte
black iMac or something I don't know
what's up with Kumar this is kind of a
long story but not really some of you
guys have seen that video where there's
like 10 facts about marques Brownlee
that you didn't know and one of them is
that my middle name is apparently Kumar
which is funny because first of all it's
not but I know exactly where that guy
got that from which is if you go to one
of those like Cora like
question-and-answer sites where someone
asked what is marques Brownlee's middle
name someone came up with this flawless
logic to explain why it must be Kumar
and then another fun fact I have a
Wikipedia page about me you you can't
edit your own Wikipedia page for some
reason only others can update it for you
so of course when this video came out
other people edited the Wikipedia page
to say that that was my middle name and
then on top of that if you ask Google
like what someone's middle name is it's
pulling a lot of that stuff from the
knowledge graph from Wikipedia so it'll
tell you a middle name is whatever the
last guess was that someone edited in
Wikipedia sometimes it's Komara
sometimes it's other names it's not none
of those are right how did you feel when
you heard Tesla upgraded autopilot
hardware so significantly after you got
your p 100 d uh in a word defeated but
it's not that bad so you might have
heard that my car Apollo which I got
less than a month ago uh will never be
upgraded to the autopilot 2.0 hardware
it is incompatible and we'll never get
retrofit so immediate when I hear that
you know I've been I've saved up for
years I've been dying to get this car I
finally get a garage I years later I get
the new announcement P 100 D I pull the
trigger and I'm super psyched and in
three weeks later its outdated for life
how does that yeah that khana is
defeating so I talked to Tesla for a
little bit I'm immediately like listen I
I want the new hardware so maybe we can
set up like a trade-in right now I'll
order a new P 100 d today we can set
this whole thing up and they kind of
talked me through it
and I'm not that sold anymore
essentially the autopilot that's in
these cars now that's coming out is
going to catch up with software updates
over the next couple weeks and years and
months
to be as good as my car now and my car
is also going to keep getting software
updates to so I don't need to trade in
right now to get that new hardware I
feel like maybe in two years I might
come back around again when there's like
a P 120 D or something ridiculous and
pulled trigger on that and get the new
hardware and get the trade-in so it's
kind of alright there's definitely some
angry Tesla owners out there who like
just got a new car and then like days
later we'll find out that they'll never
get that autopilot 2.0 kind of rough how
are you feeling after that loss last
night so Ryan is asking about my
Clippers losing to his Thunder I don't
feel that bad about it my Clippers
actually I think they look really good
this year it's early season and we did
lose to a great Thunder team and I'm
just going to say it now the MVP of the
2017 season Russell Westbrook so I'm not
that mad but I like our bench I like our
studs I think we stay healthy
we'll go deep in the Western Conference
which is a gauntlet again how would you
react to your first video now alright
welcome to my first video what a new
laptop and the media center removed with
it quite a nice room so quite a nice
remote um DVD button will play DVDs
it'll open up the DVD is I can't can't I
can't watch the whole thing uh that was
really bad but I'm glad I made it was
the Craig federighi Apple's idea or
yours so I did get to interview Craig
federighi is you've probably seen in
that previous video that was Apple
approached me for that so that's
probably all I can say about that but
also fun fact about that I didn't know I
went to the event I didn't know who I
knew I was going to be interviewing
someone but I'd know who I was going to
be interviewing until like 45 minutes
before I got to set up the camera
equipment and do the interview so that's
number one and then of course you know
some people are saying y'all those are
great questions those are really fun the
others were saying oh you went way too
soft on him you should have grilled them
on the SD card slot and the missing
features on the MacBook Pro yeah you're
probably right I was pretty happy with
the questions I came up with in the 45
minutes that I was sitting there before
I got to do the interview but I would
happily gladly interview another person
from Apple in the future just saying are
you going to do a giveaway
it's been a long time since their last
giveaway man love your crispy videos
Thank You Bogart 25 appreciate that glad
you like the videos and yeah you're
right it's been a while since I've done
a giveaway video well on a second let me
get something you see this you see this
right so I clearly don't need this many
pixels I don't think I've ever said that
sentence before but I have a bunch of
smart phones here pixels and pixel
excels I'm only reviewing one I'll
probably only keep one or two but I'm
gonna hold a giveaway on Twitter and the
upcoming days from one this video goes
live so if you follow me on Twitter
it'll be the first link below that like
button then sometime soon you will see
the giveaway tweet international
giveaway feel free to enter thanks for
watching seriously thanks for watching
these videos are really fun to make and
the only reason I get to make them is
because you guys send your questions so
yeah thanks and talk to you guys the
next one peace
[Music]